a streaker on the field in Buffalo has
the longest run of the day for the bills
three UCLA basketball players are stuck
in China and nobody really cares and
Roger Goodell wants fifty million
dollars a year a private jet and health
insurance for him and his family for the
rest of his life okay this is sports
without balls oh hey happy Monday
November 13th people of the worlds I
know we have a lot of listeners in other
countries you guys what a Monday I'd
like to start out by saying I'm trucking
a coffee that Trish Suhr brought me
because I was late in flustered always
happy to help a work commitment and I
lost my mind and thank God
Tricia's has control over you know
pretty much everything and calm me down
I have always be the Andy Richter to
your Conan you know that Trish Suhr
everybody we have some we have a
fantastic guest of today I can't believe
she hasn't been back sooner that's
because of my scheduling problems she is
a CNN lady yes contributor and a leader
and contributor I'm contributing on the
sports / social issues CNN sports /
social contributors CNN and also sports
without balls college football reporter
Erica Davis I'm clapping for myself in
themselves and a big round of applause
for Erin in the booths a lot of Winter
Meetings first of all let me just tell
you you know you have you have a Monday
morning and it's just a GD delight to
see you ladies to the right of me right
back at you babe what we got here early
yeah now let's tell everybody what you
two were discussed when Eric Eric and
I've never met in person and she's first
of all you
doll and I in that southern so she knows
I don't mean that inside sexual
harassment like you don't have enough
skills way thanks Harvey yeah thanks
Harvey
poor every poor white man can I tell you
it's so amazing every poor white man now
is petrified they're gonna get called in
some every minute every white man I've
ever they don't you desert even if there
are nobody even if they're a solid
citizen they're petrified they've done
something like hold a door too long like
everything that wouldn't be construed
I'm like it's okay everybody still have
chivalry it's cold yeah but Erika and I
instantly we started looking over what
we're gonna do today on the show and I
y'all know how I have been in the past
about Kaepernick but I will say he if
you don't know he has gqueues Citizen of
the year he's on the cover of GQ right
now on a great cover the shots beautiful
very black panther esque it's gorgeous
shot the images inside are stunning
there's a beautiful shot of him running
with a bunch of children if you haven't
seen it yet demonstrate its beautiful
and I will tell you I'm tickled that
they named him Citizen of the Year
versus like a man of these okay because
I feel like that's a little too much II
like okay for containing what it means
because I do think okay he has what we
were just I was telling Eric I had not
agreed in the past with Kaepernick's
divisive Nasir wise taking a stand for
something that I have no I mean nobody
gives a [ __ ] if I got up and did
stand-up and took an A for the quality
but I'd do it but we do we do actually
yeah we do care because as a white woman
in America you know and as white men
white people in America your voice means
more than a black person's voice so I
was here we do give a [ __ ] actually well
a nice thank you that's sweet but that's
not sweet it's the truth but you know
what I'm saying I say it from a place of
I tell jokes mm-hmm I don't my job is
not so life-changing I can tell you what
I think but I don't get paid for that
it's the point of my story okay I get
paid to tell you fun mess and tell them
I'm all mine those stories he played
football played played technically okay
so has the skill set of a quarterback
and that's
that's a job like your job unless it's
like you know I just feel like at the
time at the time we've covered this a
thousand times yeah it was very divisive
career-wise mm-hmm I think what happened
since the train left the station and he
chose he could have been like I was just
doing it for a minute or became a face
of something because I'm sure I'm not
I'm sure he said it death threats right
people probably come after his mom and
daddy nasty nasty mask that's disgusting
right and I know it's a polarizing topic
but I've loved it they made him a
citizen because whether people like it
or not it made you look at your stance
on racism in America first and that's
why I'm tickled to death that they did
it because it's a solid citizen move
solid citizen
yeah and to your point about citizen
like I guess it's a semantics thing I
mean I wouldn't have been offended
obviously cuz I'm a Kapernick thing and
I'm an advocate of everything he's done
to bring I guess visibility to these
polarizing issues in our country I would
have been fine with him being called Man
of the Year even though that might have
been more polarizing I think that's the
point I think in America we've gotten to
the point where it's like I don't want
you to protest because I'm uncomfortable
well guys protests are supposed to be
unassailable and before we before the
show started we were filming thankfully
because we were well and I come from
this place of in it has I think it take
things to a simpler of the simplest form
in this sense of simply mmm-hmm we're
comedians we're hired to make people
laugh and have fun
simply okay he is a person who is an
athlete paid to kick carry throw run and
do a ball right wrong I mean if that's
what that's what he gets paid for but I
I think it's so problematic Trish that
we look at professionals as being
one-dimensional if you're a teacher not
only are you a teacher you're a
babysitter you're a mentor if your
principal you're an administrator you're
a mentor you're a father figure to
people if you're a coach like every
every person who's any who was in any
profession where you're working hand in
hand with other people your job is
multi-dimensional but they're not
they're just he looked up to because of
a choice that I've chosen to apply a
professionals but
that's where I get saucy it's come with
the territory though I mean that's
that's just like I mean that's just
looking you could say anything about any
profession right you know what I mean I
feel like that's just well that's why I
say solid citizen meaning he I love that
that's what it was because to me being a
good human con to each other and solid
citizen just be a good solid human he
has taken what he didn't necessarily ask
for this is where it's like I don't
think he did it originally with the most
you know Gandhi s contentions I think he
embraced it and took it to that next
level that's that's what I genuinely
appreciate and applaud about him because
it has cost him to a degree his NFL
career currently it may rally back cuz
he does have a skill set and still young
enough to do what he needs to be doing
so I say I applaud that he didn't back
down to save a dollar because I felt
originally it was for a dollar that's
what I'm saying that I really do respect
that he was like I've stood in it trains
left the station and guess what I'm a
damn conductor and I love that about him
it is custom his entire NFL career sure
to be clear Tom Savage is the backup
that's now starting with the Houston
attack oh my god Tom Savage no offensive
yes I hope he rebounds but I think Mary
Foley would be better than Tom fat
Savage that's my mother hey mom so the
fact that Colin Kaepernick is not at
least getting a shot at the Houston
Texans job and then scroll down last
week I think we established after my
crazy a quarterback annales that a third
of the NFL is has shitty quarterbacks
yeah starting quarterback Oh No starting
yeah starting quarterbacks yes she had a
moment I posted it on our Instagram
people were so hilarious about Erin's
rabbit hole she went down she made up
her own stat sheet I could just go down
the list we don't have time because I
really want to get this move in but we
could just go down the list and I could
just really quickly probably give you
six or seven teams right now that
Kaepernick is better than their starting
quarterback so for sure it has cost him
his entire career
there's no foreseeable future where he
gets back on an NFL field so you're
right Trish and Erica you're both right
I know you're coming up from a little
bit of a different slant but for him to
get citizens Citizen of the year again I
would have been happy with man of the
year but citizen the year I'm sure
that's probably too polarizing whatever
but citizen of the year
ah thrilled yeah yeah I just thought it
was a very and we if you have a role
also sorry to interrupt the support
system after like the total fall out
when the entire message was misconstrued
that he has been picked up by a lot of
people you're jay-z's white black
whatever race and gender which I think
really helped solidify his point and the
movement and people just being like wake
up you can't sweep this under the carpet
yet again and I was trying to remind
people that if you're one of these
people whether you're a millennial or
older who champions and who reveres
Muhammad Ali you cannot in the same
breath vilify Colin Kaepernick because
Muhammad Ali you know what did not
believe in the war and he also was a you
know fist throwing up my fist you know
I'm for black people helping black
people I'm against police brutality I'm
against the unfair treatment
mistreatment of minorities that was
Muhammad Ali's whole thing people want
to remember what they want to remember
about him that also the change of
religion can you imagine
Muhammad Ali did that today can you
imagine I know it's different time but
yeah come on so I just want people so as
you as you are reviewing Muhammad Ali
remembered that even though Collin
capricans not the champion that Ali was
they are fighting for the same kinds of
ideals I think I know and I've leave it
at this I think Aaron knows my little
brother is a Navy SEAL when it all went
down originally my brother had
physically just come back from a mission
in middle of nowhere we're both huge
sport thank you for his service I will
tell him I'll make you but yeah thank
you girl it's a team sport but he had
come back and it all had just gone down
and he was like what is his damn problem
like so my first initial view was with
my
it was like dude it's real easy to do
when you've got a bunch of people out
here very very you know from a place of
it's a it's a privilege
it's an American privilege this is a
black privilege white privilege
it's an American privilege that you even
get to do this is a damn job like you
could be you could be out with a gun
over your shoulder fighting for your
hometown because it's getting bombed on
a daily so that's him that's where my
brother's brain came from and I of
course was like oh my god how offensive
how awfully offensive you come home from
being away from your wife and children
to see this mess and you're a huge
sports fan mm-hmm and you go oh gods
night write this crap and you take a
knee so that's where the original and I
think a lot of people came from that I
was about to say a lot of people that
even now think what all NFL teams are
doing when they're locking arms or
taking any that it's against the
military I'm like absolutely so
infuriating like if you're telling Colin
Kaepernick you're like how did this go
so but that is construed because because
it really became I believe and this gets
back to my great disdain for Roger
Goodell I believe that the NFL spun it
to be an anthem protest versus besides
race because all of a sudden that
becomes massively polarizing in a
billion dollar industry right it's much
easier and cleaner to be like he's
taking a knee cuz he doesn't like this
country right than it is to really bring
up a real uncomfortable issue yeah for
sure that's that's where it was easier
to make a country angry right cuz if you
say you don't like the troops
burn in hell there's every color out
there fighting for this country I know
Goodell who we can't stand and maybe it
will just jump to his jokes we can his
requirements his sang on so let's
transition into that real quick but I
just I wanted to say that now I'm
probably gonna can't remember the point
I was going to make she'll have two more
sips of that comedy what was right
before when it was military base that he
they really went after I oh yeah yeah
I'm sorry the whole transition at
Goodell is I think the only thing
Goodell was smart enough to do
was not immediately require and demand
right that the players have to kneel
because that is yeah she's gonna have
too much I say I am so lucky to have
Erica interest to the right of me this
podcast would have been like already
well my car would have been underwater
be talking about fishing holy that's a
good segue enough to rip on Goodell and
then I want to jump into college
football because we have our college
football correspondents oh it's so
excited excited mmm Goodell wants 15
million dollars a year if you don't know
Roger Goodell NFL Commissioner is up for
a contract renewal and you know their
list over this what he wants is 50
million dollars forty nine point five
don't make him grow sorry Marty died
point five a year it's just to just be
like okay okay what time's the game
start a private jet and health insurance
for his entire family and himself for
life for life though don't forget the
for life for his life I mean no one gets
a severance pack I don't care if you're
the head of waste management you're les
Moonves at CBS
ain't nobody getting that damn severance
pay like what in God's name what does he
do what does he do what does he do when
I'll back up Eric if you don't know the
history of Goodell and you made up
because you're incredibly intelligent on
this he started at the NFL as his first
job and certain his Paul Tagliabue
driver yeah his driver right some
[ __ ] never had another job but hold
on but what he is college-educated
though is it but I mean like you know I
remember my social security number and I
can do a beer bong not like a okay you
know 15 million dollars a year to head
to head a business or an enterprise that
basically I'm not saying he isn't he
isn't worthy I'm not saying he isn't
worthy of a salary but when you're
talking about fifty million dollars for
him just to kind of keep everything in
place I'm gonna take over him st. I'm
gonna take up for him you guys are gonna
probably jump across the table and slap
me cuz I'm not a good deal fan at all
but you know when players ask for like
these huge contracts and like the random
guy nine-to-five plumbers at at home
saying you should be happy you have this
job why are you asking for so much money
well the way I look at it with Goodell
as I do with players is that there's so
much money in the pot through so many
you got you know you you gotta ask like
the NFL is not hurting from no you're
right and you're right he knows that
what the NFL brings in per team that
they're able to afford I mean it's it's
it's probably consistent with what is
working let's be clear he makes 44
million now peep right people act like
this is some drastic jump right what
he's asked I mean put your brain around
that I cannot believe he makes I guess
yeah I do it was high but I had no idea
we're talking these numbers yeah you
know here's here's my thing and I know
this is like holier than holy but here's
here's what a good Commissioner does
like a like a commissioner that doesn't
ask for 49.5 a jet and health insurance
for his family for life you know what he
says he says you know what um I don't
need to be making that type of money I
mean they're gonna stay at my salary or
take a cut and we're all gonna use that
money to improve player safety we're
gonna put it in a pool and if someone
hurts themselves we're gonna do I don't
know it's just something charitable
something you're gonna take care yeah
but let me just finish that's what I'm
saying like he should write so if you're
gonna get paid that's why I'm like yeah
he can ask for it but for this son of a
[ __ ] to ask for fifty million dollars
he just he does nothing good nothing
good he's he's literally dropped the
ball literally literally and
figuratively
on every single domestic violence issue
like and then Olson Jerry Jones is
ripping him a new one so he's like six
games on Ezekiel Elliot's now Jerry
Jones wants to get all the owners
together to extend to deny the contract
but the rule is like six right six
donors so you know Jerry Jones says
connect as a point a question does
anyone know because I don't know that's
what I'm asking what the process is like
cuz to me it feels like a weird
dictatorship like why in god's name
wouldn't they just replace him because
the he has to have pictures of some of
those owners like having sex with a goat
genuinely no cuz I'm going why would you
not just get rid of a human being
because you wouldn't be in place if it
wasn't for these owners why wouldn't you
just put in somebody
because they're making a ton of money
under him and he besides besides with
the protest thing and maybe the
mishandling of the domestic violence
issues which I think the NFL owners
could honestly give a [ __ ] about and
don't don't think oh now they care about
race relations whatever I know so I
think it's just they're making money
they don't have they don't what NFL
owners getting slapped with any fine or
punished I am no the only thing was
Ezekiel Elliott and then a vote is mine
and maybe deflategate and maybe deflate
which which to me is hilarious that that
was like on par with yeah Ezekiel le
yeah I'm going no it's it's ridiculous
mention you're going yeah I defeated
football and beating a woman no I mean
it's maybe it's ridic we should have a
little bit of a sliding we'll see what
happens the rich take care of each other
I mean that's just I mean we all look we
all do if we don't have that kind of
money yeah we take care of each other
but we don't count
I'm saying like it's all it's all
wonderful when we're like oh I'll snatch
your coffee don't worry I'll get you an
extra pickles on your sandwich at
chick-fil-a but on their level it's like
I don't worry you make sure yeah I'll
cover that up don't worry your wife can
have health insurance for all her boob
job needs while she said something
Twitter accounts it's fine it's fine
yeah yeah no that's really it's it's the
underbelly of oh it's just an underbelly
it's just a gross gross gross fat
corrupt belly ah let's talk about
something fun like the NFL this week a
college near the college to college oh I
know listen Erica for you listeners she
was on oh god maybe a year ago year and
a half ago now a huge Georgia fan of
Georgia graduate of the Sikkim Georgia
and you know Georgia if you don't follow
college football and you should if you
don't and you should I
here's I don't follow every week I watch
highlights my sister's a professor at
Baylor so I started watching Baylor and
that didn't go well
they won their first game though they
did win a game no I mean just the
offseason oh yeah disgusting behavior I
was likewise really now and yeah no
comment on that because my sister's
employed there go bears and oh I forgot
now we're videotaping wonderful okay I
have mixed emotions cheering for Baylor
let's I think that's the legitimate
there but I have to say this it is
around the see you know this season
especially in the last couple weeks like
for instance we were in Arizona and I
was glued to the TV to see Ohio State
and Penn State I watched all the big
games right but now it feels like
legitimate all in and the crazy thing
about college football I know you two
are looking at me I know you know this
but listeners who aren't familiar every
week is do or die
everyone pressure on these kids it sucks
because you and NFL have an opportunity
to suck for three weeks if you need to
six week or sickly they need to but and
college football you lose that first
game if this super early you know you
have a little bit could you deem
yourself but if you lose the game late
depending on who it's against thing
you're kind of done and at this point
every game for the top ten teams is
essentially a playoff game and there's a
lot of pressure for 20 nights or 18 year
old little boys kids let's go over the
it was so cute to she said hey Trish we
play each other Kentucky we play each
other this week and I go no we done okay
I don't know we don't we've got Kansas
tomorrow I was having a panic attack
because as a Kentuckian we don't
acknowledge the footballs right yeah I
was like no we it was so precious today
oh my god
what does it feel like to be a winner
for you what are patriots you cheer for
the Patriots I have been a patron for a
long time but no and that's disgust yeah
hard time hard time oh just the cute
Brady year all right so let's let's
start with Georgia and then we'll do
standings and games coming up
overall here's here's my first question
well let's let's start with Georgia okay
I apologize my brain is working at about
a 65 percent for a CT a CT CT there's so
many times I've hit my head onto the
wall
because Carol my assistant is just
nowhere to be found or my giant sorrow
and 89 what is in the words of Hillary
Clinton what happened what happened what
happened was any like my Georgia people
fans following know that I've been
worried about this Auburn game for a
month I mean like there were this the
South's oldest rivalry and it was really
it really yeah you don't know what that
really means it's like look up you know
Jory Albarn playing at UGA in 1996 and
you see our mascot literally trying to
fight and not fight we'll fight bite a
player like it's a real blood collection
so people the rights type [ __ ] we have
to keep Erica cuz she's precious and I
love her so fun you're so fun so I've
been afraid of this game but the good
thing about it it was an awful loss like
literally got raped in the booty no KY
jelly and lover a lot that I'm gonna try
to forget and it's okay you know it's
okay so what happened technical tell me
technically we we just our defense or
secondary dropped passes penalty after
penalty after penalty
we had a great opening first opening
drive but Albert a wanted it more I know
that sounds so cliche and just but they
wanted it more I mean we were the top
ranked we were number one in the nation
in the CFP poll which is only pull at
this point that matters and when you're
number one the nation you have a target
on your back
yeah but girl I just looked up the score
well within 40 right it wasn't good yeah
I didn't even 1700 we ended up squat
right I got so drunk off of Jameson not
I was not emotionally equipped to deal
with that but I've been there girl
so yes so we penalties mistakes are but
I this is what I say that was our life
you guys remember I think was 2008 when
Florida was undefeated and they lost to
Ole Miss yeah and they went
but empty will write that with our I
know you T Bohemia this there will never
be another team that place thing that's
a were cut up for the rest and I will
try it I will wake up every single day
at four o'clock and I will catch paper
cheese 1700 times this but I tell you I
will never there won't be a back and let
me tell you that was that was awesome
and you should you should play Tim Tebow
and his 30 for 30 because that was good
can you imagine Tim Tebow I tell you
right now
I wonder Mary and I will ask you Erin
seriously that's my emotion right now I
like that I feel like of course our
quarterback did not say that in our
coach Kirby he's very understanding
second year at Georgia so he's trying to
be a leader by not saying too much I
appreciate that but I feel like that was
our own miss game our Tim Tebow moment I
really do believe that we are going to
win out we play Kentucky which is not a
real team but not a real team no it's
not look you know it's bad when the fans
are just plowed drunk no they even walk
in the stadium the players to problem
players might have been taking a nipper
three and we don't even know what
happened that's just to see a blue and
someone screams go cat we don't know
it's it's a hard time but your
cheerleaders are cute we're fun and we
are named by the way they're higher
ranked in the football team I mean
really they're usually number one in the
country and that's true that's right we
got to get our win somewhere that's what
you got basketball hey basketball season
s started don't worry we are number five
against number currently ranked 5 in
basketball go cats all right let's talk
this I got I'm peppering me with
questions ok yes yes I did think I saw I
didn't see the game I saw the highlights
I also felt like it was like a little
bit of the how do you call the
expectations the stage bright lights got
the got the better of them and it
happens every single season and it
happens in every single earns a really
tough Stadium play I say Tennessee
Stadium Nealon
that is one of the craziest places I've
ever seen a ballgame it is perfect most
intimidating Stadium oh my god Nealon
Stadium in Tennessee and then Auburn is
it Jordan here I believe that's the name
of their stadium they'll do very tough
places to play now our freshman
quarterback true freshman did go to
Notre Dame and lead us to a one point
victory over the Irish and everyone was
like oh he has you know the balls the
gumption to stand up to the plate in
these big pressure situations I think he
does but all burns a different beats and
they're number ten and we were number
one at the point yeah yeah we had
penalties I just I just think the
culmination of everything it's a lot to
ask for a true freshman quarter because
they're gonna get overwhelmed I have to
say this and you're not gonna like oh
god I don't want the curse you out of
your own shell um
please sir crispy out okay all right I'm
just gonna say Lisa I have a soft spot
for Auburn because because of Jarrett's
tetum Stidham stood ham he was a
quarterback at Baylor okay and came in
when this is like maybe two years ago
whoever the quarterback it was a senior
quarterback for Baylor it was like a you
know who's doing really well and he had
that are terrible no no this was just
like literally like like two years ago
and he got a terrible neck injury
right so this guy this kid Stidham comes
in I'm probably not pronouncing that
right steed 'm s st idh a.m. it looks
did ahem sit ahem
did immersed at him let's say Stidham
okay this kid comes in now I remember
him because that was that was Terris
first year at Baylor right and I was
watching every Baylor game and Terah was
not watching any of it and I watch every
single game and the quarterback goes
down neck injury this kid comes in true
freshman
and I he was amazing he was so fun to
watch then he goes down with like a knee
or leg injury right so then it was like
third string I don't remember that it
was a bowl game two years ago Baylor
against I think it was North Carolina
where Baylor had no quarterback if all
three quarterbacks were hurt and they
wound up beating North Carolina because
they ran the ball 790 times right
it was just cuz I watched it at the time
and I have a memory problem I have no
idea how I woke up but I could tell you
between Baylor and North Carolina two
years but this kid right right and
Baylor system crashes all that horrible
assault all of it the cover up
everything disgusting
which mind you probably happened on
every college campus at Baylor if it
weren't not at UGA yeah except for
Georgia obviously people are very polite
all right but this kid transfers he
drops out a bill he's like I don't want
to be associated with any of this has to
like sit out a year and now he's the
starting quarterback at Auburn that's
the only reason why I know because I was
like oh I loved that kid so I started
watching plus I always root for Auburn
verse Alabama because I cannot stand
Alabama and so that's why I was like I
felt bad for you but I was happy for
know this had I known that before you
asked me to come in I would not go
Georgia now on go Bulldogs go down I
have no connection or tie to Georgia
your personal happiness in the matter if
if there is a game listen Georgia when
does Georgia doesn't Georgia play they
Kentucky then you play Georgia Tech and
then we have the SEC Championship and I
will be right so I will be I will be
cheering your Georgia in the Shu
champion yes it's gonna be Georgia
Alabama okay well it broke well well it
is so we're on the east in bamas on the
west however Bama still has to play
Auburn so we we've grants we've clinched
the East already so we're already in the
game so you might play Auburn again and
if we play Auburn again let me tell you
I'm gonna drink all the Jameson all the
Johnnie Walker blouse and right next
ring we will all watch that game
together
I don't want it again I seriously do not
want it again I don't want it with them
because I again they have something to
prove it also I think we match up better
with Bama largely because our head coach
is a second year head coach he was under
Nick Saban for seven years as a
defensive coordinators Kirby smart
literally should have bamas player be
smart how do I know
well he's our second year head coach he
was the defensive coordinator under
Saban for seven years
he um played at Georgia he was a mute
played at UGA maybe maybe I know him as
a player maybe no miss a player be smart
that name sound so familiar but I mean
he's the coach of the formerly number
one team in the nation so there's a lot
of talk about pretty smart Ginn the
coach of the year but that's probably
how you know him that's my coach maybe
that maybe that's it
Kim Lapointe let's just discuss take 30
seconds how much I hate Alabama I I know
Nick Saban's a genius but I can't I why
do you hate Alabama
I can't he is so arrogant he says all
the wrong things how many episodes have
we quoted Nick Saban saying something
disgusting and terrible and awful just
lives in his own kind of you know as we
all know you get at a certain point and
in any career but you get a certain
point where you are above the law
if you will and Saban's just been there
for so long
did he bosnian headlines yeah let me
take an NFL coaching job and then just
quit four games in how about that
remember that Miami Def Jam remember
everyone was to its standing up it was
like Popovich all these coaches came out
of nowhere to support he was either
women's March or the Trump can't like
write he literally it was that awful
quote of like I have I have no place and
I have no place in society to comment
anything or something like that you're
like oh oh oh but you do we'll have the
number one college football program in
all of college football forever he kind
of just things like the Bill Belichick
like rel in a sense like Bill Belichick
would never comment on something no just
don't comment on it don't say it a mout
to comment saying I shouldn't come at
you and you're like go [ __ ] yourself if
you have valid charge of boys you are in
charge of 18 19 20 your influence over
these kids to do the right thing is your
civic effing dude and as you say this is
the difference right in my mind and we
were just discussing when someone
whether you like it or not getting back
to Charles Barkley like I didn't ask to
be a okay great but but as a coach that
you are that's what yeah don't you do
yeah it's actually in your job
description and it's much different much
different when you were in call
yeah and down than it is obviously a
Bill Belichick who does have I don't
wanna say underling coaches be assistant
coaches like a better word junior
coaches to take care of younger children
younger kids when they come into the NFL
on their team that are still baby
children because that's what that's what
Bill chicks out there to do that build
chicks there to get wins and craft a
bigger game plan right Saban is in place
who has I'm sure junior coaches to be in
charge of these little children's
well-being who I am you know has to get
them some Taco Bell because I don't have
two nickels to rub it on fun but don't
say crazy mess at least get up and just
don't say don't say I can appreciate it
pick your line and don't yeah it's just
it was so I don't way there's I could
stack up the list of reasons I can't
stay and I've been but I also appreciate
that he's an amazing coach yeah I think
you know if you were from Alabama these
are glory days right you know he gets
the best players he does great things
with them not taking I just don't like
him and I I don't like I also you just
get so sick of teams that win and win
and win and win and wins yeah I mean I
mean I know listen I definitely hope we
be accepted if it's your team well if
it's your team you're here eleven it and
also like at people I think across other
power five conferences conferences get
tired of FC c-- fans cheering for each
other and I don't know if that's a thing
and like the pac-12 or the Big Ten but
even though I hate Bama and the world
hates Saban I appreciate that he's a
savant and I appreciate that people who
players who commit to him think about
Georgia you know after they you know
commit to them or or or or they might
say oh it's either Georgia or Bama so I
guess the the benefit of having a Saban
in your conference is that you get his
leftovers and that sounds you know and
that is why SEC fans are such homers for
the entire conference because there's a
trickle-down effect so you might hate
saying it and I may hate him I don't
want to lose to him when we play him but
I'll take your leftover players who
don't want to go too far from home I
also think Alabama players like if you
take college football players from
Alabama right we have Landon Collins
he's one of my all-time favorites when
he's not just like you know taking a nap
for the last couple
which is understandable because no one
it really wants to play can't wait the
fever y'all give her that you lie you
lie you're no Joe oh wait wait
finish this thought I will jump right
there all right no she might stroke out
only rule
don't don't rip on Eli Manning or Derek
Jeter and we're gonna be totally okay
because I am a little bit too I was oh
my god I'm gonna have to defend them
you're not down a crazy mess road and I
yes bring me back
I let me say this the only position that
has not done well historically under
Nick Saban is the quarterback earth
because the o-line
is so good from Alabama that they have
89 minutes and then they ulsan they get
drafted to the Cleveland Brown right
actually don't bother having an office
also the SEC like we're not a
quarterback conference we're running
back conferences like you know Georgia
is running back you you have running
backs in a lineman coming out of I mean
like these are big stinging that like
Midwestern boys he had to eat corn been
self eat cornbread chicken-livered Stace
freakin awesome
you're a so that's not that's not just a
Bama thing I mean we have Matthew
Stafford coming out of Georgia we got
Peyton and Eli are examples but oh you
but specifically worry Alabama
Erica I see you I see you all right
let's do this games coming up right now
this is well this is just an NCAA this
is AP top 25 right now isn't it
Tuesday's that comes out Tuesday at 4
o'clock Pacific time we'll have the
actual official CFP poll and that is the
only poll that matters so let's discuss
this poll because this is what we have
right now now the Bama number one you're
gonna hate it
Miami number two which let me tell you
have some big prospects convicts round
two
wow that was a beatdown expected that
whoa TV timeout please I just want to
say to everybody who is still hanging on
coach Rick's nuts because you know who's
our coach for 15 years and then we fired
him oh that's right
now that Miami just because Miami is
doing will does not mean that we did not
make the right decision to fired him I
believe that there was some politics in
place that were not allowing coach Richt
to maybe be more creative offensive that
it wasn't allowing him to be as
creatively offensively I think that now
he's calling plays again and I think
that because the other power schools in
Florida are not recruiting as well I
think that he has a perfect storm of
storm now so all you Georgia fans who
and my classmates who played on a coach
Richt listen I know that's your coaching
there's your homeboy know he was your
mentor slash father figure but piece the
F out the coach Richt it was time for
his ass to go but that's beautifully
said cuz a lot of times you just have to
call Julie change the color at the
school and it doesn't mean they're a
crappy coach yes it's just the culture
at that school has to change
thank you and it's it is it's it's a guy
that is batting 212 he goes to a new
team he's bats 312 thank you it's just
different time different places like
listen Giants are doing well let's get
rid of Coughlin and bring bring Ben
McAdoo us no Peart no experience and he
slicks back his hair and he said the
head coach and go oh and 90 anyway so
Alabama number one Miami number two
oklahoma 3 Clemson for Wisconsin there
Lou they're gonna lose it we're not
going wisconsin' 5 Wisconsin's gonna be
a team Aaron Foley is gonna keep our eye
on because I love medicine Wisconsin our
burn six George's all the losses above I
don't get ahead it'll probably change
oh hi Oh state eight there's the dark
horse Notre Dame nine I think they're
out of it Oklahoma State 10 USC moved up
to 12 okay well I'm a pac-12 lady
why just as I live out here and my ex
was Washington State so then I just I
know this to researching all the pac-12
everything we broke up it's fine she
broke my heart anyway in we're back oh
you're back you're back
no I don't know were they no no she's
she said she didn't want to get married
she's a wife and kid anyway here we go
so
it's totally fine everything's gonna end
up and I'll go get her a second and a
day later here we go everything's gonna
be completely fine cuz you know trumps
oh yeah we're all gonna die all right
did you see the latest about Trump
asking the Chinese president
yep that we're getting to that sorry I
jumped the shark because the stuff that
makes me cry see lets do because I know
we have a bunch of other stuff to get to
but let me tell you this you put on your
future hat mm-hmm
give me mm-hmm give me this give me some
bold prediction for this weekend's games
or just we're doing we're doing rest of
the season who are you keeping your eye
on besides Georgia Court who's your
dream top four oh okay my dream my dream
top four mm-hmm okay so if I am correct
I think one in four get the Rose Bowl
and if that is correct I would like for
Georgia to end up either being one or
four because we live in LA just one
forget that is it SEC isn't it it's the
the the this is Sugar Bowl in the end
the rules but I don't I can't remember
who gets do they rotate which is the
national championship gamers and always
the Tostitos
well now that now they're out of BCS now
so no we don't do that anymore so now
the championship game this year is in
Atlanta so into it so to answer your
question my dream top for Georgia
against everybody else thank you but who
I think is gonna actually end up in the
top 40 is gonna be Oklahoma
I think Miami will end up in the top 4 I
do
Clemson I do I do because Miami will
they'll play each other they they play
each other right the winner of Miami
Clemson gets in so yeah so the winner of
Miami Clemson gets in the winner of Bama
Georgia or Bama Auburn will get in
[Music]
Oklahoma and then Wisconsin I don't I
don't believe in what's called don't
have Michigan this week well they've got
mission they've got the bigwigs they've
got but if Wisconsin beats I think they
have something like Michigan Ohio State
and I'm gonna put oh hi Ohio or
something I don't know if they'll get
unscathed but it's gonna be interesting
if everyone just keeps winning in
Wisconsin's undefeated it won't be
like really like you mark my freaking
word was kind of marker this one back
there undefeated at this point is still
somewhat beyond me but that that that
will also work it I tell you out of all
those teams obviously I've got it now
you know cheer for George you know I'm
all in with Wisconsin what my fate one
of my favorite comedy clubs is comedy
club on state Madison Wisconsin I love
deaths in Wisconsin she I've got a
jersey from a lady gave me literally
ripped it off her boyfriend that was a
women's hockey n-c-double-a Wisconsin
Jersey that's in my she loves I love
Lambeau Johnson I love this guy I love
cheese curd he loves cheese cards she
loves a cheese cart I love the diversity
I like the borough crew is one of my
first hats
I wanted a fair when I was seven the old
Milwaukee Brewers now I got a lot of
ties when I don't have a horse in the
game this is how I may feel can you hate
Baker maybe I don't like deshaun Watson
love love why do you love to shine and
not love Baker oh we don't have enough
time okay
because he doesn't mouth off he doesn't
run onto the field and stick a flag and
flip everybody off in midfield
I just doesn't it's not even him it's
it's the arrogance of the of the I love
athletes they do their job they leave no
but the time like oh who are you Baker
Mayfield you know what people like Baker
Mayfield do they give a story lines they
make the whole season to come even more
to life because if it wasn't for
personalities in Mallen if you're right
I just don't like them you need a
villain that's fine and you need a
villain
I tend to side with the villain yeah
except for Trump ah yeah well said no
you do you do you need all these
personalities you need you can't like
everybody
not liking someone is so fun Oh see how
I do really usually like everybody
that's why it's hard for me having
somebody hateful mess like Roger Goodell
then I try to avoid and then the Sun
[ __ ] keeps popping up like a bad
whack-a-mole
it's also fun to hate team you know hate
obviously I'm joking but like really
dislike teams for the stupidest reason
yeah I am the queen of that yeah Queen
of that and it's fun that's what makes
sports fun I'm gonna say Clemson
it beats Miami Clemson gets in I'm gonna
say Miami doesn't get in Oklahoma if
they went out there in I just cannot
beat pick Alabama cuz it just they are
beatable though they are beautiful
they're definitely beatable I read a
report this morning that like four or
five of their linebackers are hurt their
their own very banged up and then that
showed in the game against Mississippi
State where they won last minute like 11
seconds left in the game although
Mississippi State had I mean they're a
solid football game I mean they aren't
as good as an Auburn or Georgia Alabama
but they are solid they've been ranked
top 25 virtually the entire season but
Bama is banged up and yeah so it would
just be nice to get some new faces in
there like I'd love Georgia I'd love
Wisconsin I'd even like Oklahoma because
the Big Ten was that big big 12 they're
big 12 it would be nice to get a big 12
team in you know just new faces new
teams yeah um I don't need Georgia I
don't need Alabama and Clemson in the
top four again going into college
football playoffs you know what I mean
they're always in for the last couple
years it's it'd be fun happening yeah I
have one concern what's your concern
George's new get George in there give
Wisconsin in there get even Miami in
there I like new teams take here's
here's just because it's just been so
dude heavy let's do two female sport
shout outs and then we'll do maybe some
pics yep and if felt and then feel-good
moment the week by Eli and the Giants I
mean we gotta talk about that they don't
get in there and just a hop up and get
in there but honestly like I I we talked
about it last week and it just it just
feels like there's nothing new talking
well no I mean it's just at the end of
the day you have to wait and see what
they're gonna do with the coaching staff
do they want to burn the whole thing
down get rid of everybody start fresh
they want to get a quarterback that Eli
can groom do they but you know it just
it depends what direction the team wants
to go in it I do think he's got a
football left in it completely your
finger fangirling right now no it's just
you know I wouldn't want I wouldn't if I
was coaching the New York Giants I
wouldn't want to get I would want to
have if I decided okay Dan David Webb
who we picked last year in the third
round if we say he's not it and we go if
we if we have oh my god I'm not being
eloquent we're gonna probably not win
another game so it's gonna be the Battle
of New York Giants and Cleveland Browns
to get first pick right so let's just
assume Cleveland's New York Giants will
pick they'll they'll win maybe one or
two more Cleveland probably won't so
Cleveland sitting with number one let's
say Giants are sitting with number two
okay if that happens it what you know
all right so where do we go what
direction we want to get I say Quan
Barclay say Quan Berkeley say qua what
you want to do running if Cleveland if
the Cleveland Browns take don't take a
quarterback right which every
quarterback in college is like I'm gonna
stay in college right and get my
graduate then I would I would say I
would take take one Berkeley because to
me he's such a game changer and Eli can
manage another year or two and then you
develop a young quarterback under up you
know what Aaron like back in the day
like when we were growing up that's what
we did like you would get a young
quarterback and he would stay under
Brady was like under a Rogers for sure
yeah and you would like you would have
two or three years of an apprenticeship
type thing but that hasn't been the case
in the past five or 10 years like you
throw Johnny Manziel out there you throw
Mark Sanchez out there you throw to
Shaun Watson out there so old-school way
I agree with you but that's not what
teams do anymore
but it's it's some teams do and some
teams don't okay okay here give him a
year I say you guys need to J a JT
Barrett I feel like a JT Barrett could
do what you lies and I know I'm not
taking JT Baird
over say Kwan Barkley say Kwan Barclay
is a [ __ ] game
Chane he is JT Barrett has good weeks
and bad weed in college football for 17
years which I like it I like I like just
27 years like at 27 on weekends GT
Barrett on my [ __ ] first pick you
know I like him right I like I'm just
wearing for him but for me I can't see
any buddy
but Seiko and Barkley if the Browns take
sequin Barkley I think the Giants
totally should get a young stud
quarterback take Eli he's gonna be
killed if a young stud cornerback starts
for the Giants next season with probably
a new thing a new no lines gonna get
[ __ ] kills so just put a light in
another let him kill them have them
you're better off in a winning
percentage with Eli and then a Baker may
feel okay
and I'm protecting the young guy until
we shore up our old line okay look what
happened to Andrew look no shoulder yeah
that's a very good point anyway ladies
all right let's do a soccer and hockey
shout out and then we'll do some picks
the women's national team had their last
two friendlies of the year on Thursday
1-1 against Canada and then last night I
tell ya I was working I had this
assignment and I was working working
working and to sit down at 7 o'clock
last night it should have been six but
Megan had to watch The Walking Dead
that's my twin sister we live together
and we're in our forties and it's fine
and so she had to she wasn't my friend
I'm seeing someone nobody paid seven
o'clock and I watched my sweets just
went roosters every kid's dad it's just
like I love these women so much and it
was the last friendly of the season and
if your women's soccer fan you are with
me preaching to the converted this year
coach Ellis has called up 30 different
players throughout the year trying to
figure out the mitt the mixes the
matches 16 year olds 25 year olds she's
tinkering taking tinkering because next
year starts the World Cup qualifiers now
there has been some games throughout
this year where you're like I I don't
even know who these people are
why are you playing a forward on the
backline where's Meghan Klingenberg
where is this person and a that you it's
it's been frustrating right so at the
end of the year we went 12 3 & 1 still a
great year but we went for three and one
verse the top 10 not great
however the last time I kill Ellis she
won the World Cup
so no more questioning I did like the
tinkering I like the new people but I'm
just gonna say this there is one player
a time and time again which is I think
the most exciting female soccer player
I've ever seen in my entire life and
that is Megan Rapinoe again oh yeah she
is 32 years old mind you there was three
players at one time that were 16 2 for
Canada and we had oh we didn't have
Mallory Pugh in but she was like she's
like 18 so you know they're coming young
and younger and younger younger she came
back from 3 she's had three ACL injuries
she's three ACL injuries just also had
her knee scoped out the season in the
middle of the NWSL she's on ik she is
Bionic Trish she if you watch this game
last night now Canada is no joke they
were a joke and now it's exciting
because there's a lot of the female
soccer has just soccer I throw it has
taken on like all these teams now France
you know Germany also the Netherlands
are coming at another where Canada has
got a fruit Faris team and this is just
all awesome for soccer but Rapinoe last
night was running circles around not
only our players but the entire team of
Canada it was awesome at the watch she's
a freaking dream since she's amazing I
missed it can I tell him that just by
pre I'm
like yeah I appreciate this she's really
just she's an amazing pleasure to watch
I got an alert on my phone um clearly it
won't be breaking news for The Times
there but um that Italy failed to
qualify for the World Cup for the first
time since 1958
just now Italy men's soccer team won't
be in the World Cup four-time champions
last one in 2006 but this is the first
time since 1958 that Italy has failed to
qualify by god that is that's like
there's gonna be riots Street yes that's
I was just thinking that themselves I
mean our men's team didn't qualify the
World Cup and everyone was napping
during right I actually watched it I was
so upset it's just you know they could
pay more so good for them they'll be
sleeping well the the women's team gets
a 62 cents on the dollar and the men's
team are buying million dollar cleats so
anyway congratulations US Women's
National Team another good year it's
been super fun to watch and the next
year we'll kick off the qualifier to the
World Cup but it was such a pleasure to
watch them and I got to see him play
live twice this year which was super
exciting when did you go to wait this
last night was San Jose but I was okay
in front of the TV you know just
criticizing people's playing while
drinking a beer and my lazy boy that's
pretty much how we do okay quick shout
out this doesn't this seems like just a
headline you gloss over but when when I
the the Olympics are coming up in
February and the sport I go nuts over as
the women's hockey team and we lose us
beats Canada five when to win third to
win third straight for to win third
straight at the Four Nations Cup that is
a hard headline because its third and
fourth first but let me tell you this
they beat the Canadians three different
times
we never when I'm telling you the the
last time we we almost came close was
the to 2014 and the goal went off the
posts I was wearing my Wisconsin it's
getting to be a lot I'm over
I'm just very excited Hillary night
Hillary night she retweeted one of my
tweets when I tweeted at her and I was
the greatest day one of the greatest
days of my life
Hilary Knight scored Amanda Amanda
Kessel her brother plays for the NHL
lady hockey
Eurus you know I'm done with women's
hockey acts oh it's fine they are there
yeah there's no checking
yeah there's crazy they've to stop on a
dime but men just barrels they have to
stop on a dime because they cannot hit
they cannot check that's crap it's
amazing they wonderful if you could take
that away and then take all the
wonderful women of roller derby I love
it I just was thinking because those
mother truckers can oh they are some
beasts yeah oh the best piece ever okay
let's do this one more really piece of
fun news wmba fans Katie Smith a
longtime assistant to Bill Laimbeer is
gonna be the hutch for the the coach of
the New York Liberty she's one of my
favorite players in the 90s she played
for Minnesota then she played for
Laimbeer in Detroit and I was at a
Liberty game in August and I and I
looked at the bench I was like is that
Katie Smith it's weird to see people out
of uniform right in a small heel yeah
hello are you anti kitten heel no no but
it's not bill yeah just wanted a boot I
wanted a boat I wanted to win when
you're not fashion-forward has nothing
to do with you can't rock a kitten heel
yeah but when you don't understand maybe
what your look is right and that is
purely me I get very aesthetic heavy
yeah when you don't need when you need a
style I just I wanted I wanted a tall
boot instead of a kitten heel but Katie
Smith is one of the greatest female boss
balls ball players of all time and the
fact that she's leading the Liberty
that's very exciting exciting do we
Aaron what do we cut for time right now
oh gosh can we through the insane speed
pitch yes okay will do and then feel
good another week I'm around we could be
we could be done in ten minutes tops
super fast okay super fast so this is
just gut okay fast good cuz I know
nothing
how did we do last week oh I'm gonna
tell you so a week ten
the NFL which was last week we had our
guest here Jenny McNulty who was a doll
and a rabbit Lions fan and we did our
picks
Aaron you came in as the big winner
right now with 1010 wins pretty good I
had eight and Jenny had nine now to be
fair we don't have Monday Night Football
has not been played we all got the
Panthers and I'd like to say yet again
your quote which I will get made into
t-shirts everybody I'd rather go to
class then go to Cleveland nobody wants
to apply for the Browns so this week
week 11 we're gonna go through very
quickly the second team is always the
home team sometimes I will actually say
it again on Act's okay here we go there
we go
week 11 first up Thursday Night Football
we've got Titans at Steelers Titans I
was just going to put the timer coat on
Titans at Steeler Steelers Steelers
we're also good Steelers it is for
everybody okay Buccaneers at Dolphin oh
no one's gonna win battle of the most
depressing TV Florida oh the Buccaneers
at Dolphins
III don't buck some bucks I'm saying
dolphins because Jamie's out home field
but they did beat the Jets but that's
not saying anything okay how much poop
is in Cutler's pants lines at bears
lines lions
let's do cards the Cardinals at the
Texans OH
Cardinal I mean if everybody was healthy
I just this Texas team I don't know I
said it I guess I guess card cards I
pick for everyone I'm gonna meet a lone
Texas Jackson I just think they need it
this week I just that's where I my guts
at okay Redskins at Saints oh I will
watch this game but I'm rollin with the
dome in the Saints Saints Saints and
this is the only time I've picked him in
here on a roll tear on a roll yesterday
was ridiculous oh my gosh that was a
that was a woodshed whopping that roll
it's a country thing and I appreciate
that understand watch how you else got a
woodshed whoopin was the Cowboys honey
oh that was a take your butt out back
pick your own switch get you that kind
of bait pull your pants down get your
right keep going keep going some angles
that Broncos bangle set Broncos I don't
think anybody's gonna win that one eight
I don't I think there's a sinkhole I'm
literally doing purely home field okay
light air bang I'm gonna say bangles I'm
gonna I'll say Broncos but I'm done
Broncos only because of the altitude I
swear to god it's the point that's an
awful thing to say okay Eagles at
Cowboys oh I'm picking Eagles cuz no
Elliot they look flummoxed I'm gonna say
Cowboys because I'm a deck Rider
yeah tall baby okay Jags the Jaguars at
the Browns oh god how exciting people
are gonna be lined up selling their
tickets for negative 1 million dollars a
Jaguar the Ravens at Packers the Ravens
still play football
yeah Joe Flacco's got a 17 years more to
go
I don't know I guess I just I have no
confidence
honest to god neither team I'll go with
I'll go with home-field advantage
Packers a Packers Hundley you had a
little bit of a coming-out party last
night or yesterday afternoon yeah all
right I'm Packers
this is Vikings I'm sorry Rams at Viking
oh no that is gonna be an awesome game
I'm gonna write that down now who would
have thought Aaron Foley pre NFL season
said I'm excited about the Rams at the
Vikings I know I would have never
thought where's the questions Rams are
just legitimately good under a 32 year
old coach he might even be 31 yes there
baking's have put it together and now he
got the whole thing is a Case Keenum or
is it a Teddy Bridgewater might be back
though though he's back technically
cried on
sidelines so such a feel-good story it
didn't make our cut but he was he was
third he was third I'm all Chi I'm
cheering for Bridgewater I am all in
with the Rams I'm saying Rams I say Rams
to say Rams to and they are so
underwhelming until this year so they
really disgust me that I have to say Ram
sorry I know I know I am too and look at
yet furthers our point and I'll go right
back into this that that we need to get
rid of the Chargers LA needs one too
many Hmong teams in the charges to the
Oakland send the charges San Diego those
poor people making a live for no warned
in brightest Pacific they've got perfect
weather everybody's pretty give them a
team yeah they like the Chargers you
think they're fun we don't care for them
or at least it into like your Belinda
somewhere in the middle okay all right
we got literally one minute to do the
rest Chiefs at John's chief said shines
oh what a nail-biter Chiefs you're gonna
well I have to see no because I'm
cheering for every other time so I'm
still cheering for the Giants okay you
want the job no no no okay bills at
chargers Oh God let's see here the
ratings are gonna be skyrocketing well
the Chargers are bills are you have no
idea Chargers are better than what we
thought are they they are but they
always do those last four when the bills
to regroup and beat the triple I'm going
bills as well ah sigh bills all right
we've got Pat's at Raiders Pat's I want
to say Raiders just got that
yes Raiders really I'll be cheering ho
hardly for the Raiders but after a
40-year old weekend at Bernie's Tom
Brady decimated the Broncos with such
precision he just he gets better every
snack it's insane it's because he's so
good on his awake he was in Costa Rica
plankin with one of his babies on his
back just so God I would make I wish I
liked it would be such a pleasure to
watch him play is joyful but I I get no
joy I'm sorry alright alright Monday
Night Football last one Falcons at
Seahawks oh that's gonna be a good game
I just I I don't know what Falcon team
is going to show up and the sea
are a little bit better and that is a
very hard saving to playing so I'm gonna
go to Hawk I'm gonna say the Seahawks to
you I mean Doug Baldwin and Graham last
week and of course Russell Wilson were
as impressive as always let's go
Seahawks alkanes okay here we go we've
got to feel good moments of the week oh
wait a minute listen a quick back on the
bus I know this is quick but a quick
back on the bus we always wind up
putting one member of the ball family
back on the bus now we have a third
member of the ball family to be back on
the bus and that is what is his name Lee
Angelo Angelo and two other UCLA
basketball players all of these
basketball players are back on the bus
they're in China what a wonderful
experience exhibition game commission
games of you're playing for UCLA
representing a country and an amazing
school and you decide to steal Louis
Vuitton glasses right from the law
because we don't have a Rodeo Drive you
could lift him from three to a story
store three different stores in a
high-end mall in China you [ __ ]
idiots we also not only that any other
NCAA athlete will tell you that's
instant grounds for removal of a
scholarship yes that is instant grounds
for expulsion expulsion from a scale
yeah right all those things and instead
of that we've got the President of the
United States asking the president of
China to step in what I do want to say
this though what's his name Klay
Thompson's dad um Michael Tong Michaels
yeah Michael Thompson mention on the
radio about five days ago he was like
wouldn't it be a great PR move for Trump
to lobby the Chinese government to let
these boys go and they kind of said it
jokingly like tongue-in-cheek hahaha but
that'll be a great PR move for Trump to
do that because he would gain so much
ground with people who love sports today
right gross I mean it's for I don't know
what the other two boys financial
situations are I would think it
financial situations I think it was just
a stupid kid cry stupid kid craft
dupa kid I want these kids out of China
I want him back home but I want them I
hope to be have the worst most scared
yeah hitless experience being under
house arrest in a foreign country and if
that doesn't right your ship set the
ship on it yeah I guess what bothered me
and we're done after this because I hate
carrying on about the ball family they
are so back on the bus Erica we gave
them their own family bus family you
know it just gets back very simply being
raised in the south good home training
good you can you can look and say that
unfortunately the culture that they have
come up in they may be exceptional
athlete maybe we don't know this well
Dean
well they you know athletic tendencies
that have gotten them to this level
right okay okay
they're home training they're so devoid
of being solid citizens okay that gets
back to solid citizen I can't I can't
ask I cannot say that because Lonzo has
not shown that he is a deviant in any
way shape or form like we're taking one
son in painting the other to know that
body language is terrible Trish Suhr
take over that argument 30 second long
secretary so they asked Lonzo after a
Laker game what do you think of your
brother and instead of just simply
saying look it's my family it's a family
situation and stealing's wrong that's
all you got to say you don't see your
brother dead and you have to just say
it's a family situation I'm not there
all right I don't condone stealing on
any level and thank God my dad's there
too you know like put it off on the fact
that it is a family matter and okay what
he cuz at the end of the day you're an
athlete that little children are sitting
there crying like you just simply say
what any human being would know
stealing's wrong but he didn't he goes
blank as a blank as a door honey blank
as a door cuz I don't know and talk to
him in China what what what's wrong with
you what is wrong with you just very
it's your brother is it brother
if my brother was in another country
arrested I don't give a [ __ ] if it's for
Louie Vuitton glasses or taking somebody
out
sumbitch I'm bouncing you would be
emotional on some right right and I'm
not saying like what getting off course
of course I bet you know Ferris he's the
best out of all of them are sure but
still it's just every single week and
now this idiot really can't we can't
hold on though responsible for not
having an emotional reaction to the
report fairness they deserve a family
bus and we've got to wrap this up okay
so they're all on the bus okay on the
bus to could feel good months of the
week now one of them is so heartbreaking
and I just a test of resiliency so the
feel the feel good is his resiliency and
then we have a story we'll end with that
we'll just just make you laugh and smile
San Francisco 49ers receiver Marquis
Goodwin
played against the Giants on Sunday had
a the longest catch from scrimmage this
season but nobody knew that on that
morning his wife Morgan I mean his
wife's Morgan's baby passed away from
complications from a premature pregnancy
he literally he lost his baby boy at
4:00 a.m. when to the field didn't tell
anyone put his helmet on played was a
huge factor in the game they beat the
Giants he when he scored the touchdown
he blew a kiss to this guy before he
crossed the goal line knelt in prayer it
surrounded like unbelievable
unbelievable this is this is why I get
angry at other players like Antonio
Bryant from the Steelers that's like I'm
playing I wanna play I'm gonna hold on I
need my my name gonna and it is a
privilege a privilege and an honor to
play a professional sport or to do what
you love every single day and get paid
for it and this guy loses his son puts
his helmet on goes to work when his and
Morgan his wife if you go to Marquis
Goodwin's Instagram and see the post
it's powerful from him but his wife
Morgan did a separate post which will
also take your heart out she's tagged in
his image if you want to see her post
and read it but she very simply says I'm
pulling afraid of statement out of her
hers which said despite our loss my
hubby kept grinding scored his son a
touchdown and got our first W of the
season he had a wonderful game today I
appreciate everyone who kept us in their
prayers first of all I mean that you
said something like that after you just
went through something so unimaginable
like what are you even on social media
but what a class act
very classy I'll be in a Booker crying
but uh but I think that's what she
needed to do to grieve obviously like
you needed to say because when you see
this it's such a beautiful it because
what people don't realize and I'll be
done not trying to make this more but
this is why it's feel good that he went
and persevered when when someone has a
child that they actually have to deliver
and it's not alive they make you have to
take a picture of it I grew up in a
funeral home so unfortunately I know
this they make you take a picture just
like when you put a live newborn because
it's part of documenting human beings
existence so you have do all the things
you do if it had lived and so that sweet
woman had to go all the way through it
and still was set wonderful and I think
what a testament to who they are and
there's so many great stories like that
in the NFL not great they lost a child
but great that they're those humans yeah
I wish those were the stories that were
told more than somebody beating the crap
out of ya their wife so anyway Marcus
Goodwin you're a rock star I was early I
want your Jersey yeah his wife and
Morgan yes so just like huge just huge
hugs to that family and I hope they have
ten kids and and and what a great way
and it was the giant so who cares it was
against Giants I had I known I would
have been screaming and cheering when
Howard that touchdown last but not least
feel-good moment of the week this was
sent to me friend of the show Jackie
Garrett you're the best
and also I fell I follow American
outlaws on Twitter which is super crazy
fun cheering squad for US Women's
National Team and and the US Men's
National Team they're just they have
different pockets all around the country
and Brit may be her last name is Senator
because her Twitter handle is at be
senator she got married and re-enacted
the brandy chastity Chastain
rip the t-shirt off from 1999 World Cup
she's in her bridal dress doing the same
fist pump as brandi chastain all her
bridesmaids are behind her
cheering and running at her like the
rest of the group in 99 they're wearing
beautiful lavender dresses with adidas
soccer of flip-flops and their full
soccers and their full soccer suit and
it was the greatest photo I think I've
ever seen in my entire life we will post
it I tweeted at her because she was like
this is the greatest day ever that
American outlaws retweeted this photo or
tweeted out this photo and I said and
also you will be our feel-good moment
the week so I'm gonna link the episode
up to her Twitter but Britt I I mean
class yeah that was so fun so creative
so feel good and so awesome so thank you
Curren graduations first and foremost on
your wedding your bridesmaids are cool
as [ __ ] you're as cool as [ __ ] thank you
for giving us that moment you effing
wrong that is our show you guys that's
our show make sure you follow us on the
Facebook and at sports without balls pot
on Twitter on Instagram and sports
without balls on Instagram and leave us
a five star review I'm gonna we're gonna
do more of these five star review on
iTunes if you go to sports without balls
on iTunes leave us a review we will read
it on the show will give you a shout out
we're working on the website and merch
that is creeping up it's gonna be
fantastic
Erica Davis thank you so much for being
so are letting me come in more in my
loss and talk about other stuff that's
more important than college football
like great football players having a
fantastic game after having such thank
you thank you thank you it's not gonna
come naturally to me
right but I will be poppy pulling for
Georgia please pull for Georgia keep us
in if you're a praying person if you're
not a premium person find God before
I need in Erika's words find God and
cheerful George that's adorable that's a
great way to say it where can people
find you every day y'all finding me and
having me um you can find me on Twitter
and on Instagram I'm always fighting
people on Twitter any time of day or
night and Erica Renee D tweet me at me I
will fight you too and then other is
what I don't fight people is on CNN
domestic and international where I'm now
thank you so much for coming on the show
and being our college football
correspondent you were gonna come back
on before the end of the season we'll
take us through the big games and then
at least a right around all the
championship week right after the
championship week which will be the
beginning of January but you're the best
thank you so much Thank You Trish Suhr
it's so good to see you thank you for
stopping me down and bringing me coffee
and being so awesome thanks and we'll
put everything everything everything's
up I'm doing it as we speak y'all it'll
be live oh and we'll have the video
she'll get to say what we look like
today you're welcome
that will be up shortly and of course
you always can go to all things comedy
com2 see any of that and we thank you
guys sports without balls fans friends
family have the best week of your life
called me four times